Frage wer weiß noch wie wir an dieser
Stelle vor ein paar Wochen mal gesagt
haben dass wir Fracking jetzt doch ganz
in Ordnung finden
das kam riesig an in der Community ja
ein grüner Shitstorm vom allerfeinsten
so und weil das so gut lief hier mal
direkt der nächste Schocker gehen
Technik in der Landwirtschaft ist auch
viel besser als ihr Ruf
ganz genau Gentechnik das grüne ja
warum reden wir drüber diese Woche war
das Thema bei einer Expertenanhörung im
Bundestag und die Europäische Kommission
überarbeitet jetzt gerade unser
Gentechnikrecht Tatsache ist über zwei
Drittel der Deutschen sind ganz klar
gegen Gentechnik in der
Nahrungsmittelproduktion das sind die
auch kein Wunder meine bewusste
Ernährung ist uns ja allen schon vor
Jahren in Fleisch und Blut übergegangen
ich bin eigentlich der Fleischesser
heute nur mal Salat was heiß ist und was
einmal in der Woche doch einmal
angebracht ist aber dann auch gerne mit
Fleisch oder Wurst
geil oder ey
Salat mit Wurst ja ich lasse dann oft
noch den Salat weg dann ist es perfekt
aber unser Thema war ja sie erinnern
sich Gentechnik in der Landwirtschaft
und die Landwirtschaft muss sich zügig
an den Klimawandel anpassen Stichwort
hitzeresistente Pflanzen so ein Weg
dahin ein Weg können auch neue
genomische Techniken kurz ngt sein also
mindestens eine echte Debatte über deren
Potenzial sollte möglich sein aber nicht
mit den Grünen und schon gar nicht mit
Renate Künast ja
sie bleibt dabei wer was gehen
manipuliertes Futter der mutiert am Ende
selber oder so ähnlich wir wissen ja
viel zu wenig und haben ein massiven
Mangel an Risikoforschung z.B was das
Produkt selbst angeht aber auch was die
ist die Auswirkung des Produktes einer
gentechnischen veränderten Pflanze
innerhalb des naturkreislaufes angeht
das wissen wir alles gar nicht sie haben
noch nicht erforscht ich meine aber
irgendwer hätte neulich das Gegenteil
behauptet wer war das noch ach ja ganz
viele Forscher seit Jahren hätten
hunderte Wissenschaftler intensive
Risikoforschung betrieben
diesen zu dem Ergebnis gekommen dass die
gentechnisch veränderten Pflanzen kein
höheres Risiko für die Umwelt darstellen
als die die durch klassische Züchtung
bisher seit Jahrzehnten erzeugt werden
und die als sicher eingeschätzt werden
na und Wissenschaftler was wissen die
denn schon ne also wir hatten fest bei
Themen wie Klima oder Corona sind die
Grünen schon Team Wissenschaft aber eben
nicht bei gehen Forschung und Ernährung
und wie gesagt da sind die Grünen
da sind die Grünen durchaus Mainstream
es ist mehr als Meinungen unser Bild von
genexperimenten basiert halt vor allem
auf alten Filmen
[Musik]
ja sie haben es erkannt das sind diese
Nosferatu spinnen die jetzt bei uns
heimisch werden
so in der Realität gibt es tatsächlich
Gentechnik die das Erbgut gar nicht
wirklich verändert die genschere
Christbaum längst Nobelpreis
Christbaum klingt wie ein vergessener
Schokoriegel aus den 80ern könnte aber
dazu beitragen dass Ernährungsproblem
des Planeten zu lösen es werden keine
fremden Gene verpflanzt sondern nur
vorhandene Gene auf der DNA der
Getreidesorte ausgewählt und
ausgetauscht die auf Viren Dürre oder zu
wenig Nährstoffe reagieren oder wenn was
heute alles geht und wer hat es erfunden
genau Edward mit den genscherenhänden ja
gut für so hergestellte Produkte
bräuchte es selbstverständlich
Kennzeichnungspflichten und
Risikoprüfung aber ich sag mal ob eine
Pflanze gesundheitsgefährdend ist hängt
nicht von der züchtungstechnik ab
manipulierter Mais ist zum Beispiel
deutlich gesünder als nur einmal
Fliegenpilze als ein Beispiel
naturwissenschaftlich gibt es stand
heute keinen Grund durch ngt entstandene
Pflanzen anders zu betrachten als solche
aus herkömmlicher Züchtung dennoch
warnte die Umweltschutzorganisation Bund
so vorgehen Technik ein Bild das eher an
eine gefährliche Seuche erinnert
kurze Frage warum trägt die Frau eine
ffb-2-maske hat sie Angst der Maiskolben
hustet sie an oder was
Bund gehen manipulierter riesen meist
übernimmt die Weltherrschaft ernsthaft
haben diese noch alle da
sehr witzig Wilke aber denk dran ich
weiß wo du wohnst mach noch einmal
Popcorn und ich schwenkt dich in Butter
du Sau
unnötig aggressiver Ton Herr Maiskolben
übrigens ob das strenge EU-Recht für
Verfahren die Christa gelockert wird das
ist noch völlig offen aber Fakt ist
Insulin zum Beispiel basiert auf
Gentechnik genau wie ein Produkt von
biontech das bis neulich hier recht
populär war sage ich mal selbst selbst
natürliche Mutation ist im Prinzip
Gentechnik will sagen wir müssen mal
aufhören mit der Heuchelei seit vielen
Jahrzehnten greifen Pflanzenzüchter auf
die Trickkiste aus dem Labor zurück
seitdem wird z.B radioaktive Strahlung
eingesetzt um Mutationen auszulösen und
neue Pflanzeneigenschaften
hervorzubringen
der Weihnachtsmarkt Klassiker die
atompilzpfanne yummy so tatsächlich
gehen jede Menge unserer heutigen
Gemüsesorten auf radioaktiv behandelte
Pflanzen zurück zum Beispiel sehr viele
von diesen leckeren Roten Grapefruits
also liebe Ökos Liebe Ökos
öffnet euch mal für die Wunder der
modernen Gentechnik außerdem gibt es für
euch ja aktuell auch einige gute
Nachrichten in Deutschland boomen zum
Beispiel Fleisch Ersatzprodukte ja die
fleisch-ersatzbranche hat allein im
letzten Jahr rund 600 Millionen Umsatz
bei uns gemacht das ist ein Triumph des
fleischersatzes das heißt liebe
Zuschauer solche Gruselgeschichten hier
gehören hoffentlich bald der
Vergangenheit an da war ich also in der
Schlange mit also
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel wir stand
dort nebeneinander und ich habe noch
versucht sie zu überzeugen dass sie
Abstand nehmen soll von diesen Buletten
merkelte die Buletten ab ich konnte es
nicht verhindern
mein Gott
was
was kommt noch alles raus über diese
Frau sie hat uns abhängig gemacht von
China sie hat beim Russen Gas gekauft
und jetzt auch noch bulettengate
Wahnsinn aber doch noch mal zu den
Fleisch Ersatzprodukten Tofu Wurst
Seitan Schnitzel das Zeug geht weg als
wäre es ja richtiges Essen und zwar zu
Recht zu Recht wir töten 150 Milliarden
Tiere jedes Jahr so kann es nicht
weitergehen weniger Fleisch essen kann
also nicht verkehrt sein ansonsten gilt
für Ernährung wie für die meisten Themen
bloß nicht zu tief Einsteigen in die
Materie Martin klemmt nur hat wegen der
Schwangerschaft seiner Frau angefangen
sich im Internet über Ernährung zu
informieren einfach hängnisvoller Fehler
du liebe gute die Klima Bilanz von
Kuhmilch die ist ja verheiratet zum
Glück habe ich gestern
ganz genauso
warte mal Schatz ich lese gerade der
Anbau von Mandeln verbraucht Wasser
wenn sich einmal mit dem Thema
beschäftigt ne
da muss man seinen Einkaufsverhalten ja
auch völlig neu denken wie viele
Deutsche leidet Martin Klempner an
Morbus Google den zwanghaften tragen
sich gefährliches Halbwissen aus dem
Netz zu saugen okay Schatz wir dachten
ja bis jetzt immer Fleischersatzprodukte
sind ganz okay aber genau die Sorgen
wohl für noch mehr Monokulturen auf
Feldern und für noch mehr synthetischen
Dinger sind hochverarbeitete
Lebensmittel Stabilisatoren Emulgatoren
das ganze Programm ich glaube wir holen
uns mal lieber so ein Vollkornbrot bist
du wahnsinnig
Vollkornbrot du musst dich mal
informieren die kleine die da drin ist
die kann unser Körper gar nicht
verwerten die scheißen unverdaut wieder
aus ja dann schon lieber die Tiere
verfüttern jetzt guckt nicht so das sind
die Fakten ich kann nichts dafür
Schatz wo bist du denn
ich komme aber ich weiß du brauchst
unheimlich viel Eiweiß ja aber Eier mal
ernsthaft woher kommt dieser
unglaubliche Hass auf Hühner
haben sie doch gar nichts getan
ach du scheiße
dreiviertel unserer Bauern haben schon
aufgegeben warte mal aber jetzt alle
kein Fleisch mehr essen dann wenn das ja
immer mehr das heißt vegan sein
vernichtet Existenzen
aber Schatz
und hier vergiss deine Mandelmilch nicht
Single sein nicht gut fürs Klima aber
super für die Psyche
das ist ja wohl hoffentlich fair
gehandelter Kaffee
wir haben gesagt die sollen meinen
Lieblingswitz erzählen was mache ich
gerne also kommen ein Pferd Jeff Pesos
und der Papst in eine Bar sagt der
Barkeeper
abonniere endlich den verkackten heute
schon
Kanada also geht doch